94 won look man I'm here hanging out
with a lot of awesome wrestlers we have
someone who is you're not of course
immediately from Tampa what is it were
you from your in the Tampa area roughly
yeah I have a lot of homes
we got Bray Wyatt here I'm from I'm from
a just a collage of all over the United
States right Wyatt man yo look I got to
tell you the last month on Raw has been
special for you what has it been like
carrying this Undertaker build-up
without him actually being there but
you've written it's really been all on
your shoulders to create that story well
I mean I'm sure you can sympathize with
this it's just when you care about
something that much it just secretes out
of you and that's what it's been you
know
the other ticker is the ultimate goal
for me I don't think I could get any
higher than beating the Undertaker at
WrestleMania so when I have that in my
head already you know it's it's just
it's just all passion you know it's so
easy for me it's been like I think I
mean obviously I feel like you keep one
up in yourself when it comes to your mic
work but I feel like this is like some
of them I mean besides what Paul
Heyman's been doing the last couple
years I feel like your promos over the
last month it was like the best mic work
I've seen in years
when 2k I mean it's been being that
you're the first guy Undertaker's
wrestling after he broke the streak was
broken I mean do you feel like any sort
of pressure to make sure that that match
is that much better
I mean I mean that's a big you know a
lot of people are gonna be looking at
that match specifically to see how when
I take a return yes
yeah and that does supression you you
want yeah what a streak no streak it
doesn't it's that it's the Phenom we hit
hold up soon so yeah and like I said
meeting the Phenom at WrestleMania there
there is no higher so as long as I just
keep focused on that the fact that this
is this is Bray Wyatt's time you know
the other taker has nothing to prove I
have everything to prove I know that you
know so it is no surprise and I've
already been my ears back and I've
already told myself mentally what I'm
gonna have to go to to get this done and
I'm willing to do that
you speak in your in your vignettes and
your promos about wanting to be you know
pretty much take Undertaker out and be
the new king of Darkness who growing up
besides the Undertaker who's somebody
who who you kind of could look back on
it as someone who also had a lot of
pioneering in the dark scary kind of
character in wrestling that's the zzj
crabbers oh man
pipe I agree that for instance I think
he's like one of the best heals of all
time and and one of the most underrated
wrestlers was he really didn't he I
don't think I'm right I believe he never
held a major title yeah I'm not sure
about that I know I'm smarter than me
but I do know that that when you ask
people who Jake Roberts as they know of
course because he had that effect of
course um the white family uh over the
past years as everyone's kind of split
up and gone their own ways Luke Harper's
definitely been doing this thing ever
has been doing this thing what is it
like man coming up with with two guys
like that you guys built something
special you guys built like a aura in
WWE that was that's been missing for a
long time and having kind of been the
guy to kind of launch those two dudes
careers are you like proud of them I
mean like what's it like seeing those
guys do their thing well it's never over
right especially here it's never ever
owners and when the time's right I think
they'll come back when I need them most
but you know coming up with them it's
real Brotherhood and we will be brothers
until we're all dead you know it's it's
a very special thing we have and we know
it and we look forward to carrying out
for years to come and we will do you
think a sting Bray Wyatt rivalry I mean
my friend maybe Joe was just asking
without really you gotta ask him what he
would think about going up against sting
potentially do you think that would be
something that you'd be excited to do of
course I think that I think next man
it's gotta be next to me yeah that's
another one of bucket list you know it's
got a couple more names on it and
they're still active and you know
Undertaker Triple H
standards I am what's one of your most
memorable moments on on role over the
last year I know for me like something
that you were involved in was when
Daniel Bryan Oh Daniel Bryan got trapped
in the ring he was a part of he was a
part of you know the Wyatt family for a
couple weeks and and then of course he
turned on you he got you in the ring
away from everybody in that crowd pop
that he got which was crazy but what
what's been the most memorable moment
for you over the last year year and a
half that you've had on wrong definitely
there's been so many and this is simple
you know I you know like I said last
time I was on here and I said Dean
Ambrose is one got a wonderf you know
yeah we talked about that that's yeah
and we had just that wars but if I'm the
SI have some great ashes man if I'm
gonna narrow it down to one moment it
was at Fastlane coming out in
Undertaker's coffin that was yo that was
that was impressive because everyone
thought yeah we all thought it was taker
and just citizen in that call what are
you making in your head when you're like
getting I mean you know everyone in the
in the audience is a man's returning it
was hysterical to me because I'm sitting
in there and I can I'm hearing the music
and you got the Druids out there and the
whole production and right when I said
that right observe this this moment of
people and then just
be in the baguette if you live for the
feeling it was yo what's crazy is I feel
like man you're like made for four
movies like I mean obviously W is
cocaine in a couple movies but I feel
like they need like you are you
interested in doing film because I feel
like you could be a really like a big
marquee guy for dub dubby films like I
would definitely do films but uh I would
definitely do films as prey it's got to
be yeah definitely you know in in your
realm but I have to press to be brave
you know I'm not gonna be in a romantic
calm you can't you can't be you know in
me and funny D so yeah you and Kevin
harder so yeah yeah oh very very
interesting Bray Wyatt likes Kevin Hart
bright what TV show you can watch
besides raw obviously I'm sure you got
it on DVR you you go back to eat
yourself watched Oh at home in I mean a
lot of people might assume you might
watch a duck dynasty based off the beard
I mean I think your your that a little
bit more yeah I'm seeing that guys they
it's cool it's okay but what do you
watch I want your Walking Dead the great
great TV I just I just met Glenn into
Austin Texas is all myself with him oh
really yeah yeah I've seen a man
Comic Con sister of course yeah they're
all right guys like I really enjoy
walking and Game of Thrones amazing I
can't wait for to come back yeah okay
maternal um it can be a winter winters
when I'm I'm ready for winter well yeah
yeah those would be my main - yeah those
are like that I like anything or or you
watch American Horror Story I do that's
a good one yeah yeah for sure hit or
miss you know this last season was a big
hit yeah I love about he's really had a
freak show was don't well look I think
what you've been doing lately is
legendary we're gonna look back at this
when you have your your first DVD
special because you know you're gonna
have a few of those DVDs come out
whatever the case be this is gonna be
like you're in your prime right now man
and and I can't wait to see the story
you guys paint at WrestleMania yeah I'll
come to periodically attempt let's see
yeah yeah we'll see you a template we'll
get some taco bus you know what taco bus
and we'll see what's up man I appreciate
you break you're the man Bray Wyatt he's
gonna win I got a feeling he's gonna
knock off the Undertaker we'll see we'll
see my son my son just beat him in in in
arm wrestling no so it was big it was
big